each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
okay everybody I think we can get
started it's my pleasure today to
introduce Kate Connolly from Indiana
University my alma mater so it's a real
pleasure for me I don't know a lot about
caves work I'm really looking forward to
hearing about it but she works in the
area of pervasive health in the computer
science department within the school of
informatics and I'm involved with the
advisory board for the school of
informatics so somehow our lines got
crossed and we were lucky enough to
invite her over for a talk so enjoyed
take it away um so what I'm going to
talk to about today is an emerging area
that really come about in the last five
years or so I think if you look like
seven years ago people started having
these workshops at Chi and UV comp all
about technology in the healthcare arena
and two years ago we had the first
international pervasive technologies for
healthcare conference and as you would
expect for a first-time conference you
know the acceptor eight wasn't something
we were really proud of and publishing
but we had it again this last year and
the acceptor it went down to thirty
percent we had so many submissions and
so I think it's really a feel that's
kind of emerging in its own right and
and i've been working in it for about
five years now one of the things that
I've noticed when we see a lot of
presentations at the conferences in this
area is a lot of people are very much
technical people they're really
interested in sensor networks and and
putting in systems into hospitals and
things like that and they don't have a
very strong design background and they a
lot of times they will design
applications without ever talking to
potential users and so the message I'm
kind of bringing out today is is
something that we're doing at Indiana
University and that's having a very
human centered or user-centered approach
to designing these technologies and some
of you if you're in the HCI field this
is going to be very familiar to you but
I just want to really try to get that
out to everyone who's involved in the
pervasive technologies for health
community so so that's going to be the
focus so i actually started out in
pervasive computing
I don't know seven or eight years ago
and I was looking at a lot of different
applications and I slowly kind of got
more and more involved in health care
because of the potential impact that it
has i think that people you know they
have a hard time enjoying the rest of
their lives if they're healthy health is
at risk or is suffering and so I've
really enjoyed working with people to
help them maintain and improve their own
help so just to give you a little bit of
context into why this is an emerging
area I think a lot of our current health
infrastructure in the United States as
well as other force world countries are
really becoming overloaded because we
have a couple of significant trends that
are going on the first one is that our
medical care is really good and so
diseases that used to be terminal are
now becoming chronic diseases and people
are living 20 30 or more years with
diseases such as cancer and AIDS and
they require significant medical
attention and so we're having to spend a
lot of our resources managing these
chronic diseases the other thing is a
demographic change and it has to do with
the baby boomers basically coming up to
retirement age and starting to
experience all the the issues that you
have when you're aging and people are
just living a lot longer and so they're
overloading those specific resources
that are targeting elders as well
another thing though that is happening
because I think a good part of it is
because people don't have the kind of
time to spend with their doctors that
they used to back in my grandmother's
day is that people are becoming a lot
more proactive about their health care
you know they can't rely on being able
to spend 30 minutes with the doctor and
have him lay or her lay everything out
about their disease and so they're doing
a lot of going online looking for
resources asking other people and trying
to be proactive in managing their own
health when this is changing the roles
that doctors and patients are playing
and this is really opening up I think a
lot of opportunities in terms of giving
technology to people to help them manage
their own health as opposed to just
putting technology in the medical
facilities so so we have a lot of
opportunities here to support these
health-related behaviors and that's what
I'm particularly interested in
so what I'm going to do is talk about
kind of the approach we take at Indiana
University this human centered approach
and I'm going to illustrate some of the
big themes with three projects that are
that are going on right now and then at
the very end just a couple of slides I'm
going to kind of announced a new
initiative that's going on at IU so the
first big theme is having a very user
centered iterative design process so you
know obviously when you're when you're
looking in the new problem domain you
want to consult the literature you want
to consult experts they have a wealth of
knowledge that you need to use but you
shouldn't just rely on the experts you
need to i think really verify a lot of
the ingrained assumptions and actually
interact with your target population we
also use a very iterative design process
and that you don't want to kind of come
up with this great design built spent a
lot of resources building it and then
say oh and deploy it and discover that
some of your assumptions were wrong or
something something wasn't working right
so you want to obtain feedback from your
users very early and often and
incorporate that feedback into the
design so I'm going to illustrate kind
of this process with an application that
we are looking at that we're developing
to help a very very sick population
manage an incredibly strict diet so I
chose this quote because it really
illustrates kind of how hard it is for
this particular population to live with
their disease they their whole life is
centered around their disease and trying
to manage their diet and and they're
very exhausted by it and it's something
that you have to think about when you're
designing for that population so the
population are hemodialysis patients oh
I'll call them dialysis patients from
now on but basically the idea is these
patients have lost all use of their
kidneys they don't function anymore and
without a transplant their life span is
probably three to five years because of
all of the complications that arise when
you don't have use of your kidneys so
essentially what happens is once every
48 hours they have to go into a dialysis
unit and they undergo hemodialysis where
they're hooked up to this machine that
you see on the right-hand side of the
picture and it acts as their kidneys the
blood is slowly removed from their body
it filters out excess fluid and excess
nutrients and then it's put back into
their body and this process takes about
four to six hours to do and it is very
uncomfortable by the end of it they are
cramping and they're really pretty
miserable they're dehydrated and their
entire lives are really revolved around
this you know every two days they have
to go in and do this so they can't have
a job often and they have to really
think about you know how much they're
consuming and it just really exhausts
them so you can imagine if you only have
use of your kidneys once every 48 hours
what kind of a diet dietary restrictions
you're going to have I mean imagine you
could only urinate once every 48 hours
that's essentially what you're talking
about so you have very strict limits on
the amount of water you're allowed to
drink as well as a whole host of other
nutrients including sodium potassium
phosphorus and is really complicated to
try to manage this as it turns out
eighty percent of the patient simply
can't adhere to this diet even if
they're motivated to adhere to it
because it's such a complicated diet one
that one study has shown that up to a
third of the patients cannot compute
perform the calculations to go from a
nutrition label to what their doctors
are telling them they can eat they just
don't have the mathematical capabilities
or skills to do that and so that of
course makes it even harder and our
particular target population that we're
looking at fiu is an urban population
that has low literacy rates some of
these patients can't even read so
traditionally what the kind of care that
they're given is they're trying meet
with dieticians and they try to review
what they're eating and help them you
know avoid certain foods and to do that
they're told to keep paper Diaries you
know write down everything that you're
eating but the compliance rate for these
kinds of diaries are as low as eleven
percent it's really difficult to
remember to write down every single
thing that you put in your mouth and
this is even for motivated people and in
our particular population since some of
them can't read when they're told to
keep a diary of what they're eating they
try to draw sketches of the food that
they're eating and you can
and how complicated and taemin sense of
that is in another population with a
breast cancer population ninety-four
percent of the patients were actually
able to comply when they had electronic
Diaries so we had the nurse researchers
who work with this patient population
come to us and they were looking for a
technical solution and you know we
brainstormed with them and we came up
with this idea which we call the dietary
intake monitoring application or Dima
and the idea is we wanted to give them
an electronic diary it can do the
conversions that were necessary it could
give them real time feedback instead of
waiting until they met with the
dietitian and maybe it could have a
significant impact on their their
dietary habits we we wanted the device
to be portable because you don't always
eat at home so we wanted something that
you could have a home but you could also
have at a restaurant or if you go to a
friend's house and we needed to figure
out a very easy way to input what
they're eating obviously if they can't
read they're not going to sit there and
type in that they're having you know
Cheetos or something like that so we we
chose to input mechanisms the first one
was a barcode scanner because most you
know packaged foods have barcodes and we
had access to a database that linked the
bar codes to the nutritional information
and the second one if something doesn't
have a barcode perhaps you're eating
fresh fruit or you eating something that
you've prepared at home we'd have some
sort of an icon interface we didn't know
what this would look like at the time
but that was the idea and then we would
always provide feedback they could
always look and say where am I and how
much I'm allowed to drink or the amount
of sodium or phosphorus or whatever it
is that the that they're consuming and
we hoped that by having real-time
feedback they be able to make choices in
real time instead of waiting until they
review it with the dietician and and
then make plans to alter their diet so
to do this because we were working with
a pretty vulnerable population one that
often isn't designed for low literacy
population we had a very intense
iterative design process and we actually
started this project back in 2005 it's
before we had funding from the NIH it's
picked up speed quite a quite a bit
since we've gotten funding but the very
first study we did was can they even use
PDAs
this particular population their
physical health is much older than they
are in reality they compare more to
elders they have vision problems they
have dexterity problems and coordination
problems that are all a result of their
particular disease and so we needed to
see if they could actually use the pvas
because they see icons on them could
they press the buttons could they use a
barcode scanner could they do voice
recording things like that and what we
found is that they could actually use
these devices but things like for the
size of the icons we couldn't use even
the largest default icon size that came
in most of the programming packages we
had to customize them so they would be
large enough for them to see and
actually we can the icons that we're
using in the device we're using we can
fit three icons in a row and that's as
much as we can fit so instead of a lot
of you know traditional PDA design has
been let's fit as much as we can on the
screen because we have these young power
users we had to take a step back and
think how can we design for this
particular population something else
that we found we tried a couple of
different barcode scanners and one that
we thought was going to be really
popular it was a little pin that you
just kind of wipe over the barcode it
turns out it wasn't very usable at all
for a couple of reasons one being that
you were trying to hold the food item
the pen and you had your PDA somewhere
and it was just you know without three
hands that was kind of difficult to do
and another reason is the version that
we used back then of the scanner didn't
have any kind of visual or auditory
indication that you were actually
successful in scanning and that was a
big drawback so instead we used the the
barcode scanner that you plug into the
top of the PDA that made by socket so so
once we knew that they could actually
use the PDA we something that we found
out in the study was we actually
performed that study with healthy young
people healthy older people and this
particular population and this was the
only population that said I don't need
anything with barcodes and they were you
know we'd ask them what they ate and
sure enough they did eat things that
have barcodes but they didn't recognize
them it wasn't part of their world in
their perception so we wanted to know if
we actually gave them a device and had
them take it home would they be able to
find and successfully scan these
barcodes and so that was the second
study that we did where we gave them the
device for three weeks and had them
and everything that they were eating and
if they couldn't find a barcode they
would voice record what they were eating
so we could come back later and train
them where to look for the barcode and
we had some really interesting results
one of the things that the nurses were
really afraid of was that this
population would not return the devices
because they thought they might sell
them to get money because it's a very
impoverished population and as it turns
out they were more careful with the
devices than any any group of people
I've ever worked with they were very
very careful to bring them back every
single time and it was a real pleasure
working with them but what we what we
discovered from this is that yes they
actually could with very minimal
training they could find the barcodes
they could scan them no problem and I
think in at the two week mark we had
kind of our maximum how much they were
scanning every day and then all of a
sudden there was kind of a big drop and
what we found was they decided it was a
little bit easier to voice record what
they were eating been scanning and so
they couldn't scanning but when you
listen to the audio recordings of what
they were scant or what they were
recording it wasn't something that you
could easily parse it was a you know
someone who couldn't read when they ate
lucky charms cereal was saying well I
had a bowl of cereal and it's the one
that had the Box on it has a leprechaun
on it and that's not something that
we're going to be able to come up with a
voice recognition system anytime soon
that can actually determine what that is
so that they can have real-time feedback
but they obviously did really like voice
so we decided for the next study to
actually pursue was this barcode
scanning the way to go or should we
think about doing voice recording or
audio record voice recognition as the
input mechanism because they tended to
like that we had avoided that at first
because the nurses said that they were
very sensitive about their disease and
they wanted to avoid any technology that
had the stigma of disease associated
with it so voice recording if they were
around someone else would be very
obvious what they were doing so we had
avoided that but we thought we would
pursue this for one study so we did this
voices voice structured voice vs
scanning study and so for half the time
they had a cell phone and they called
into it a number and they went through
this menu and they recorded everything
that they
eight and the other half of the time
they had the scanning application but
they didn't have a voice option in the
scanning application this time and we
were comparing how much they were
actually and what kinds of things they
were actually recording with both
mechanisms what we found here was very
mixed result and at this point we really
could have gone either way with the
design they actually said they preferred
the voice recording but as it turns out
they were actually less successful at
voice recording in the kind of detail
that we needed to actually give them
real time feedback what the reason it
turns out that they really liked the
voice recording was because they like
the form factor of a phone they liked
having a cell phone on them whereas the
PDA was a bit larger and bulkier but
with the scanning they were recording
more things they were recording more
detail about what they were eating and
and far less detail and even success in
getting the voice recognition software
to work with with the cell phone so we
decided to continue with the scanning
and and the PDA solution because it also
allowed them to have that real-time
feedback every time they turned on the
PDA where's with the cell phone we would
give them the feedback over the phone
but then they have to call up if they
forgot what their values were so we
decided to stick with the PDA although
we might have been able to make either
gone either direction there so the last
study is we've been talking a lot about
the scanning well not everything is a
barcode and this is probably the more
complicated of the design process why do
we want to actually do if they need to
find icons how do we how do we structure
it in such a way they can find the icon
easily enough that they're willing to do
it because they have very limited amount
of icons that can fit on the screen so
we did to two studies and the first one
we were looking at just high level kind
of navigation do they like to organize
things in terms of time of day or food
groups or some other way and we also
looked at the feedback icons you know
what phpbb we gave them a number of
different kinds of feedback icons what
could they interpret correctly in terms
of where they were in their daily limit
consumption and the most interesting
thing that we found out of this study I
mean it did help us with the kind of
high
navigation but with the feedback icons
we found that they actually preferred
icons that they did not interpret
correctly and so we couldn't use those
icons obviously it wouldn't be useful if
they couldn't understand where they were
in their daily limits but if we had just
kind of stopped at what is your
preference we would have picked
something that was really very bad for
this particular population so we ended
up using an icon that they could
interpret correctly even though it
wasn't their preference and then the
last city we did was more how do you do
the navigation so that it's not too
complex and they don't get lost and we
tried a variety of things everywhere
from you have tabs maybe a tab for each
food group all the way to you have back
and forward error arrows so if you
accidentally tap on the right right icon
you can go back up to the previous page
and then and then follow it to very
linear where you had to just keep going
down the step and if you've got lost
press home and start at the beginning
and it turns out that last one is the
way that we went with because the other
two were really complicated and they got
lost and confused about where they were
so so as it stands now for the for edema
you you're basically building a meal you
say you're going to want to either scan
a barcode or select an icon and then if
you're in the icon interface you work
your way down until you find your food
so you might pick okay grocery store
items or fast food if you're in the
grocery it's a fruit it's a red fruit
now there's my red fruit and if you if
you accidentally pick the wrong thing
you have to press home and start at the
beginning and this was the one that that
people got lost the least and confused
the least
they got very confused with the back
button where they were and what they
were doing and part of it is so for
fruits and vegetables you could pick
fruits you can pick vegetables we then
went with color after that is it a green
fruit is a red fruit and if they they
got confused in my in the fruits and my
in the vegetables and it really was
difficult for them to actually complete
the tasks when we had the back button
not all of them but a lot of them
question but they may have a little bit
they could select so what we did is and
yes we did the question was did I did we
tailor the items for this particular
demographic we have soul foods for
example and because we're dealing with a
large african-american population we had
done several studies where we were
recording everything they ate over an
extended period of time every food that
was ever mentioned is available in this
icon interface and then we have an easy
ability to add I'm about to talk about a
study we're about to do and if a new
food pops up we can have that rolled in
by the next time that we see them so
just some emergent themes that came from
one or more of these studies the first
one is when you're talking about giving
technology to everyday people it's
really important that you integrate into
their daily routines and as an example
of this you know we originally thought
we were going to have one device it was
portable so they could use it at home
they could use it when they're when
they're out of the house and it turns
out patients either use it for one or
the other they don't tend to take it off
the kitchen counter and then go out to
eat and then come back and remember to
put it on the kitchen counter not all
but a lot of them had had issues with
this so even though our current NIH
grant doesn't provide funding for us to
have two separate devices that's kind of
the future iterations we're going to
have something in the kitchen that stays
on the counter and then the portable
device and it's something that we didn't
anticipate and it came out through these
these kinds of studies the as I
mentioned before the nurses were really
worried about the stigma of disease and
they didn't want us giving them anything
that would say I'm sick well as it turns
out this particular population is so
sick that their entire life is defined
by this disease
everyone they know knows they're sick
and and they're completely overwhelmed
by it and giving them a piece of
technology was actually the one bright
shiny moment that they had associated
with this disease and they really enjoy
showing it off to other people in fact
so much we have to be really careful
about data analysis because when we're
going along looking at all these
barcodes of scanning and all of a sudden
you have a session that has 30 barkos it
includes paper towels and bleach and
everything else you have to wonder okay
maybe they're not eating this and so so
so actually we might want to utilize the
fact that in some populations in some
situations technology is a status symbol
is a good thing and I might promote
adoption the domain experts did not
always have it right you know the the
technology is a status symbol is one
example but what the nurses think the
patients are eating is really pretty
wrong including the dietitians what the
dietitians think that the patients are
eating it's not what they're recording
and that's not what they're telling us
one of the major things when you have an
illness that is so restrictive is you
want to cheat and you don't want to tell
your caregiver because you don't want to
be nagged about it and so you need to
actually build these technologies so
that the patient can reflect and what
their actual behavior is without
necessarily telling someone else what
that is so the nurses had had in the
beginning one in the next iteration of
this application to be networked so they
could get real-time notices if someone
was drinking too much or eating too much
potassium and they could intervene right
then and give them a call I think if we
did that you'd find that the patient
population would lie to the technology
then and they wouldn't be honest with
themselves they wouldn't be able to
reflect and see that oh I am cheating
more often than I thought I was because
they're not going to they don't want the
nurses to know that and I think that
that's really important when you're
talking about health care building in
this ability to cheat on whatever your
regimen is okay so that is kind of the
wrap-up of why i think that the user
centered iterative design is really
important we saw a lot of things that we
wouldn't have gotten from the nurses if
we hadn't really gone in there and
worked with this particular population
oh and we have the prototype now and
what we're about to do is we have an
nih-funded pilot study or
we're going to have six weeks they're
going to be 20 patients actually using
our application another 20 in the
control group where they are getting the
technology but it has something very
minor about looking at your daily
activities no feedback or anything like
that because we want to make sure that
giving them technology isn't what
motivates them to change their behavior
but it's actually doing the elec the
tracking and if this is pasta if this is
promising then we're going to go forward
with the clinical trial and for me if
you guys are HDI researchers in the
audience this is really exciting having
a study of 40 people over six weeks with
technology is a really big deal in this
domain and the clinical trial we're
talking about hundreds of patients and
so for me this is just wonderful to be
able to team up with a group of
researchers who this is just normal this
is how you have to do research to have
these kind of large studies alright so
the next kind of idea that I want to get
behind for you know things that we do
when we're looking at these kinds of
health interventions is looking at the
existing behavior theories that are out
there and Mary's going to know all of
these really well since she's in
psychology but uh there's a lot of
existing literature out there about why
people behave certain ways and how they
behave changers or change behaviors
sorry and and I think that it's really a
useful for technologists to understand
what those theories are so they can
think about their interventions in terms
of those theories and maybe target them
more specifically for what they're
trying to do so this is a really famous
one in the health information area it's
a bandura's social cognitive theory
there are many kind of versions of this
this is our interpretation and some of
the kind of key constructs that come out
are things like self-efficacy people
have to feel confident that they can
actually do a certain behavior in order
for them to do it otherwise they won't
even try you have behavior capability so
this is having the skills to actually
achieve whatever behavior you're wanting
so in the case of Dima we were really
affecting this behavior capability by
giving them a tool that allowed them to
adhere to their diet whereas before they
had no idea what they were doing with
respect to their diet and that in turn
can can help their self-efficacy and
you have a lot of other things including
social persuasion so you know your
social context really has an impact on
what you're doing and in fact there's a
kind of a recent study out there where
they were looking at overweight and
obesity and they were looking at the
social networks and if you have a lot of
friends that are obese you're more
likely to be obese so social networking
your social networks actually have a
very significant impact on your health
behaviors and then also of course
reinforcement you know if you're if you
see changes or if you're congratulated
for achieving a behavior you're more
likely to continue so this is one of
them another one that I really like is
to transfer reticle model and it's the
it looks at the stages of change and you
go all the way from pre contemplation
where you it's not even on your radar
you're not thinking about change too ok
now you're thinking about change in
contemplation you're thinking maybe you
want to do it preparation you've decided
you want to change your behavior you
start planning it action you're actually
changing your behavior and then
maintenance and termination on the thing
with the stages of change model is that
you move back and forth between stages
all of the time and what you want to
think about with a technology
intervention perhaps is maybe you want
to target one or two stages maybe the
contemplation in preparation and see if
you can move people to the next stage
that would be a success so it's not
necessarily saying anyone who is in this
this population I want to give them this
intervention and I want to see that they
actually maintain this positive behavior
change instead with your user studies
perhaps you want to say I want to look
at people who are thinking about making
this change and see if I can get them to
the action stage and that would be a
success and I think that a lot of times
researchers just open it up to anyone
who's of a certain age and and and so
the results are very mixed because
you're going to have people who are at
different stages here so so there are
other models as well those are just two
that I particularly enjoy and so I'm
going to kind of illustrate this with
this the second project which looks at
physical activity so JFK gave this quote
many years ago and talking about how
we're under exercised as a nation and
some of the older people in the
room probably remember he had this
president's physical fitness being in
the elementary schools I remember
receiving my certificate really trying
to encourage us to be more active and
our youth well the situation's a lot
worse than when JFK was around in the
past 20 years the rate of obesity and
adolescents has tripled so were worse
off than we were back then and it is due
most likely to reasons that you could
guess inactivity so we're not being
physically active we're sitting on our
bums a lot and driving in our cars and
poor dietary habits we're eating a lot
of junk food and fast food and things
like that so this particular project is
focusing on teenage girls it was
actually a part of the student design
context i student design competition a
few years ago and I was the one of the
faculty advisors for it and the the team
chose the teenage girls for these three
reasons girls tend to become more
inactive than boys and adolescents
because boys are still encouraged to do
sportswear as girls tend not to be you
want to be girly they also turn to more
unhealthy weight control methods such as
anorexia and bulimia so this has
significant health impact for now and
for in the future but as it turns out
some studies have shown they're also
more receptive to to interventions at
this stage for changing their behavior
and so it's really an ideal population
to look at they kind of have the worst
possible implications but they are
receptive to changing so so they decided
to look at this and they came up with
this project called chick click and they
got the name from the actual user
population they didn't come up with it
themselves and they won the competition
that year and we then proceeded to
implement it and do a user study that
was in pervasive health earlier this
year and the they did a couple things
that are grounded in that bandura's
model of behavior change that I had in
that first slide the first thing is they
wanted to model positive behavior so
they wanted girls who maybe weren't
being as physically active to see other
girls who were being more physically
active so they could see that well if my
friend could do
it then maybe I could do it too they
also wanted to include a lot of social
support and so they had this clique of
girls so they would have up to four
girls doing this application together so
it was utilizing their existing social
networks and trying to have this social
support and then and then they also have
this verbal persuasion was actually text
messaging so not verbal but they had a
way for girls to give each other
feedback and really encourage each other
the idea behind it is that the girls
would have two devices with them they
would wear a pedometer all the time and
they would have a cell phone and the
cell phone was running the chick click
application periodically throughout the
day the girls would enter the step count
that they had and it would automatically
be sent to their friends phones and then
that you could see how much the other
girls had had entered that day and you
could look at your current group process
so progress so here a DD entered a
thousand steps maybe you know early in
the morning she went out and took a
morning walk and yesterday she hadn't
walked much at all she had gotten beaten
by her friends so you can see kind of
progress over time and and so this is
how we were utilizing that social
network in addition you have we built in
text messaging into the application so
you could easily when after you would
look at group progress maybe you would
go and you would send a message to
either the entire group or a subset of
the group encouraging them in some way
so for our user study that we reported
on earlier this year we actually
recorded all of the text messages that
the girls sent to each other not just
within this application because we
wanted to see how the texting with about
physical activity might differ from the
other their other texting as well so I
don't have time to go into a lot of the
results but here are just a few things
that we discovered and the first is we
the girls really didn't know how to talk
about physical activity in a positive
way they didn't say anything negative
but they just didn't know what to do and
they felt kind of silly about it and so
we needed to incorporate some sort of
scaffolding that wasn't there to help
them formulate here's a good kind of
message that you might want to send so
perhaps some templates all of the girls
thought had a very positive experience
but they could see how this could become
negative
in some situations especially if it was
done over a long time and people got
super competitive they thought that that
could actually have a negative impact on
self-esteem in the future and so you
need to be careful about that and so if
this was part of like a program that you
would have in your gym classes or
something you would want to think about
having kind of short targeted
interventions that were somehow
supervised by the the instructor so that
you can make sure that it remained a
positive experience for everyone another
thing that we might be able to do
instead of having direct comparisons you
know Richie had six thousand steps today
and I had 10,000 I beat you haha you
know we could show comparisons in terms
of your own personal goal you know so I
am you know three quarters of the way to
my goal so is Richie we're equal here
and so we can be positive in encouraging
each other to reach our goals even if
those goals aren't the same reciprocity
is really necessary when you're relying
on social support we had one group of
girls there were three girls one of them
essentially didn't participate and the
other two eventually dropped out too
because I just didn't feel like they
were getting the same thing from the the
third participant and so you either need
to build in a way for this kind of a
game to prompt the users who aren't
participating or think about how can you
keep the other people participating even
if one of the people drops out and
finally it was really critical to have a
self-selected small group of friends
when we talked about you know would you
want to do this with the entire class no
way what they want to do this with the
entire class would you want to do it if
you just kind of had some random people
assigned no this is way too sensitive
and so they wanted to choose other you
know their girlfriends who they felt
would be supportive in fact when we were
looking at the text messaging in general
from the girls that weren't related to
this application they were incredibly
supportive they were talking to each
other about their boyfriends and their
parents and all of these other things
they didn't necessarily know how to talk
about physical activity but they were
really supportive of each other and
there are other other life situations
and so I think that that was was an
important part of the application to let
them choose who is in the group with
them so that's the second kind of big
thing we talked about iterative design
process
we talked about grounded in some
behavior theories the last big thing
that I think is really critical in most
ubicomp applications but especially in
healthcare is having these Institute of
Al uation if you just show people
something and get their reaction that's
telling you that's telling you something
about their attitudes about maybe
whether or not they go to the store and
buy it but it's not telling you anything
about their experience and how they're
going to experience it and I really
advocate strongly for this another thing
is a lot of times people are very
excited about a technology but as soon
as that wow factor drops off they
stopped using it and so you want to see
if you can actually integrate it into
their normal life processes so that they
would actually keep it up maybe if they
don't perhaps like Deema perhaps it's
just too hard to actually record all the
time we actually had a lot of
participants telling us so far that this
would have been perfect when they were
first diagnosed to help them stabilize
their diet or maybe once a year they
would want to use it for two weeks to
kind of reflect and stabilized but it
might not be something that's
appropriate to have every day 24 7 so
this last project that I'm going to talk
about is actually looking at elders and
technologies in the homes of elders to
help them maintain their independence
how are we doing on time is it ok and
one of the things that a lot of people
look at with elders is look at physical
safety and physical health but I think
that this quote kind of illustrates our
philosophy at Indiana University where
your cognitive well-being and your
social well-being are just as important
because they have very dramatic impacts
on your physical health as well so we
want to look at kind of the whole
picture not just the physical health and
the project is called ethos it stands
for ethical technologies and homes of
seniors and it's really motivated by
this demographic change that I talked
about in the beginning with the boomers
retiring we're basically having a much
larger percentage of our population is
going to be elders by the year twenty
thirty in fact if you look at people 85
or over that's the fastest growing
demographic in the country so
and if you I just heard a recent
statistic although I don't have a
citation for it yet I'm trying to get it
if you reach the age of 80 you're more
likely to live 10 more years than you
were in the previous decade so if you
reach that you're you're you're pretty
healthy and you're going to going to be
around for a while and so because of
this you know we're about to overload
the infrastructure for caring for elders
the technology holds a great promise for
helping us deal with this with this
problem and a lot of people are starting
to look at how technology can keep
people in the home longer as well as
help and assisted living facilities and
things like that a recent number i heard
was that it costs on the order of ten
thousand dollars a week if you take
someone and put them in assisted living
facility as compared to if they stay in
their home so there's a few huge
financial incentive to start looking at
this area one of the things that we've
seen especially as we you know in the
last five years is when technologists
are looking at this issue they
completely punt on the issue of privacy
I you know I've seen quoted in papers
when they try to address privacy issues
they'll say things like well either the
older person is going to give up all
their privacy because they're moving to
assisted living or they can give up some
to that technology which would you
choose okay that was in a I i I'll go
look I was in a spectrum article I
Tripoli spectrum and so so they're
basically saying you know they don't
have a choice I think this is a really
bad way to frame the issue for a number
of reasons one is many of these
technologies are being designed
specifically to help loved ones decide
when an elder needs to go into an
assisted living facility helping to make
that choice so they're looking for
trends over a long period of time so by
definition we're asking elders to take
these technologies into their homes
before they're being forced to that
decision so so we have to start thinking
about the ethics involved in these
technologies or you know they're still
independently living they can refuse to
have them completely so so we shouldn't
punt on the issue another thing that's a
little more selfish is if you look at
any kind of technology like this that
maybe starts for one target populate
it bleeds out into the rest of the
population so we need to be thinking
about these issues from the beginning so
as it turns out if you look in the
academic literature there are a whole
lot of ways to think about privacy and
here's just four of them and I don't
even have my head around all of them I'm
not the privacy expert that's on this
particular project but you have
everything from some seclusion which is
the right to be left alone other people
can just go away and leave you alone to
autonomy the right to do what you want
autonomy is a real big one with elders
just in general because they don't want
to give up control over their own lives
to property and this is the legal
reality we live under whoever collects
the data owns it and can use it pretty
much whatever way they want it's a very
different model than you would have say
in Europe to spatial things and this is
really pertinent if you're talking about
things in the home you know you might be
perfectly comfortable with a certain
technology in your living room but
you're very uncomfortable having it in
your bedroom or in your bathroom so
different spaces might have different
privacy expectations the problem when
you kind of look at all these different
paradigms is that neither designers who
are designing these technologies or
elders who are using them the consumers
of them really understand them all that
well you know a few might but in general
they don't because it's not something
that we we think about every day and so
if you sit down the designer and an
elder and you say let's design something
that is sensitive to your privacy needs
it's really a challenge because we don't
really have a good way to communicate
with each other about these and we're
not all well versed in and what the
various implications are so what we're
doing in the ethos project the main goal
here is to develop this toolkit which is
in year two we just finished your one
we're starting near two and it's
basically a way to enhance this
communication between the designer and
the elders and their loved ones so we
have a participant evaluation tool where
the goal is to take them through a
series of questions finding out what do
they care about what are they sensitive
to who would they be willing to share
this information with but you just can't
come out and say it that way if you you
know paint a scary scenario and say do
you care about privacy everyone's going
to say
I do but if you actually try to walk
them through well you know do you mind
having this in the bedroom that might be
very different than then you might get
very different answers so we have to
construct this using the language that
elders would use and trying to think
about how they actually think about
privacy and what terms they use and then
we'll also have this designer tool which
the designer will use as they're
actually putting in different devices
into the home it can actually flag them
if something violates a concern that the
participant actually indicated in the
previous tool so it can assist designers
and in designing something that is
sensitive to that particular person's
needs because everyone is different let
me tell you and then finally we have
this library which makes it really easy
to implement basically it can you know
obscure time stamps aggregate data and
things like that to make sure that
you're not just monitored you know
tracking every single possible thing
you're you're gathering the information
that is important for your design and so
it's not going to be reused perhaps in a
way that you didn't expect it to at a
later point and so what we've done this
first year is we set up the living lab
and that is a picture of it and it's
basically just a one bedroom apartment
the idea is not to bring elders and to
live there but it's to contextualize the
prototypes that were what we want to
talk to them about so that they can try
to get a better sense for how these
technologies might be embedded in their
own homes and it's just an intermediate
step and and then we do a lot we did a
lot of focus groups where we're trying
to understand how olders talk about
privacy without actually bringing up the
term privacy ourselves so you know they
came in for these focus groups and we
would ask them things about usability
and need and where would you put this
but we didn't mention privacy until the
very end then to make sure that we
actually covered everything that we
needed so we've done that and again it's
more to understand how they think about
privacy not to come up with a
one-size-fits-all privacy solution and
then that's going to build into this
toolkit and then in year three we're
going to be doing this longitudinal
study it's going to be at least six
weeks and hopefully if we can afford
more it will be long
but we're going to have four families
and they live in a retirement community
in Bloomington we're working with the
retirement community and we're going to
have four groups of student designers
designing for these families and 12 of
the groups are going to be using this
tool kit and two of them are not and
we're going to be able to then try to do
an evaluation on you know how were the
privacy needs or concerns actually
addressed in in the designs based on
using this tool kit was it useful or not
so I'll talk just briefly about a couple
of the prototypes that we're looking at
in the focus groups we actually use
things that were off the shelf too we
had like this big honkin medicine
reminder that's really ugly and we used
that and we also developed our own
prototypes because we wanted to get away
from just you know medicine adherence
and and and physical safety we wanted to
look at some other aspects because there
are different kinds of data and
different uses of the data if you start
looking at say social applications so we
designed some of these and Richie
hazelwood's and the audience here he's
had a heavy hand and a lot of what I'm
talking about right now so this first
one is the ambient plant pot and you see
that there are two pots in these
pictures one on the left side of each of
them and the idea is that they simply
have a motion detector on them and if
you walk by one of the plot / pots in
one home the other one is going to
slowly flash this kind of deep blue
color so you can see that that someone
is by their pot at the end basically and
the idea is just to give people a feel
for kind of the daily routines that
people are undergoing so in this case we
actually deployed it and there was a
sunroom here and the the older couple
kept the pot in the sunroom and they
spend a lot of time there and their
daughter kept it in her own home office
and one thing that we found in the focus
groups almost universally this concept
was disliked nobody could get their head
around why you would want to have this
and in fact the participants who
participated in this study they thought
the same thing at the beginning of the
study they looked at this and they're
like you know we're really uncertain
about it but by the end of the study
they didn't want to give it back to us
they
they had to experience it before they
could actually understand how it could
be useful because it wasn't feeling an
immediate need that they saw but they
would be sitting in their sunroom and
the plant pot would go off and they'd be
like oh you know Lisa's working at home
today that's so nice and they just
didn't realize how nice of a connection
that would be to kind of see the daily
rhythms of their loved one's household
and so it was the attitudes really
changed after experiencing it and I
think that you see this a lot in in UV
comp in general this second one I don't
have a good picture of because it's
actually implemented in a mirror and you
know how difficult it is to take a
picture of a mirror without just seeing
your own reflection so I I put up one of
the initial sketches which isn't exactly
what it looks like now but it's the
mirror motive and it's basically having
some sort of a reminder system embedded
in an everyday object so a lot of people
have mirrors on their home and they
chose the mirror to do this and so the
final one doesn't look like this but
basically when you come up to the mirror
a motion sensor can detect that you're
their proximity sensor and then if you
it might ask you have you measured your
blood sugar today and you just kind of
wave is it to adjust your interaction
yes or no or it might ask you if you've
taken your medications or it could even
ask you you know if your daughter your
daughter could submit an invitation and
it could say johnny has a soccer game
tomorrow do you want to go with them yes
or no those kinds of things so it has a
little bit of monitoring because it can
kind of it can tell your your responses
to meeting medication adherence but but
it's mostly just a reminder system and
what we found interesting in the focus
groups we haven't actually deployed this
one is that people just inherently
trusted this system they didn't really
worry where the data was going or what
people were doing with it so privacy
just wasn't even on the radar when they
talked about this particular system when
they talked about the ambient plant
privacy did come up a fair amount so
this last one is the portal monitor and
there are actually a few different uses
of this it's basically having cameras
around the door and the first one that
you see here is anytime someone rings
the doorbell three quick snapshots are
taken
and it sent via the cell phone to
whoever you designate so it could be
your daughter or your son and and the
idea here is a lot of elders are fall
prey to people who are trying to scam
them and your your son or daughter could
just see oh you know I recognize this
person that's fine you know it's it's my
it's my dad's friend Joe he came to
visit or you could see some construction
like looking guys trying to sell them a
new roof and you can you know give them
a call or call a neighbor up and and
help protect against that kind of
predatory behavior another way that this
can be used we actually have a camera
pointing from the outside and from the
inside and every time the door opens the
snapshots are taken and sent to the cell
phone and this can help prevent
wandering if your if your parent is
starting to lose it a little bit
cognitively and then all of a sudden you
see your mom is walking out in the
middle of winter without a coat then
maybe that would give you cause to
concern to call someone who's nearby and
people the the people in the focus
groups really really liked this
particular idea because it focused on
the physical physical security and and
it was a need that they could
immediately relate to they had all these
horror stories of you know people being
taken advantage of or people going out
and wandering and so they could really
relate to this one and because of that
they were really comfortable with the
fact that there were pictures or even
video being taken at the door they were
fine with that but things like the
ambient plant not all of them but
several of them were very concerned that
well that's kind of like big brother
somebody knowing that I'm walking in my
kitchen now and so even though its
motion it's a very low signal you know
they were uncomfortable with that
whereas a complete picture was perfectly
fine for them and so I think that that
just kind of illustrates how you have to
contextualize the kind of data and what
it's being used for for people to really
be able to react appropriately you can't
just say video you can't just say
pictures you have to understand what
they use is for okay so just some
initial results because we're just now
transcribing the focus groups and we
haven't done the data analysis but
unlike the chick click application where
reciprocity was really important here it
actually made elders on
they you know they didn't mind
necessarily having the plot plot the
plant pot in their house they might not
understand why it was used but they're
like okay it can be there but they felt
like it was an intrusion of their
daughters privacy to ask her to put it
in her house and so that they could see
and so we had thought that reciprocity
would be really important to encourage
them to adopt if they could see their
kids and not just be the ones being
monitored that would be make it more
acceptable but that's not necessarily
the case they felt like they were
intruding data as property even though
it's the legal system under which they
live it's kind of a foreign concept they
really didn't talk about it in terms of
property they talked about privacy and
other terms so that's just interesting
in and of itself because because it's
you know the legal reality is very
different than than what they they think
about and that the data granularity is
not the deciding factor you know how
much information is being given is not
the deciding factor here it's how it's
being used and end the utility that is
giving a between response you know
physical security falling down these are
concerns that they really have and
they're willing to give up a lot for
that actually they might not necessarily
be willing to give up a lot but their
friends would and that's something else
you find a lot with elders they do not
visualize themselves as being older and
needing these kinds of technologies but
they all have friends who could use
something like this and then finally
just longitudinal in two studies give
you very different results than if you
just bring them in and ask them a bunch
of questions I just wanted to put up
real quick the other faculty who are on
this just to show you the kinds of
collaborations you need to have to be
able to do a project like this you know
we have gene camp who is our expert on
privacy lisa huber she is a specialist
with elders and have been working with
them for a long time and we have a
social scientist who's really looking at
our methods as well so so those are the
kind of the human centered approach that
we're taking a die you we have this you
know iterative human centered design
process we ground it in behavior
theories whenever we can we do a lot of
Institute's you longitudinal testing
which is very
expensive but well worth it and then in
this ethos in particular we're really
looking at the methods of how to elicit
be privacy concerns because you just
can't ask the questions so the thing I
want to announce is that is really
exciting to me is we have this really
large security group in at Indiana
University and they're all listed here
everyone from a lawyer here to Gina
mentions the private privacy specialist
at cryptographer network specialist
trusted computing etc and we've recently
all gotten on board to look at pervasive
health applications and we've gotten
funding from the lilly endowment to have
this new Institute in fact dennis was
integral in getting this funding and
then he left us but we're going to be
focusing our security and privacy work
on this particular application domain
and i think that's really exciting
because you don't see a lot of people
out there doing that and in hopefully in
the spring but perhaps next fall we're
going to host a workshop kind of like a
grand research challenges workshop where
we're going to bring leading researchers
around the country both on the
technology side on the privacy and
security side and the healthcare side
we're going to bring them all together
try to identify what are the major
challenges that we need to be looking at
over the next 10 years if we're hoping
these technologies are really going to
be pervasive and helping us with our
health care and and and I hope that will
help define kind of some of the research
agenda in the future so look for that
next year if you're interested in this
definitely get in contact with me we'll
be having a solicitation for basically a
short proposal on why you would want to
attend the conference and what you would
have to add to it because because we
want to issue this report that will have
a big impact so that's my talk some
questions
questioned who came in lakes if you
already covered that the name apologize
did you also to get sensors that think
in that when people actually fun oh when
I call
the air bags of the college right so we
have not done that although I think that
it's a very interesting area the focus
in the ethos project was really to try
to come up with a variety of types of
applications that address different like
social physical different needs just to
facilitate the conversation the end
really was not in the prototypes
themselves but it was in what what is it
that makes this data gathering
acceptable to you wear something else
might not so we ended up talking a lot
about fall detection because I was a
need that a lot of people saw and so
even though we didn't have a prototype
for it there's a lot of conversation in
there about fall detection and in fact
the plant pot people kept trying to turn
it into something that would just detect
if you had fallen because if well if I
didn't walk into the kitchen then my
daughter would see and then she would
call me and discover that I had fallen
and i won't be left there for 24 hours
so they even though it's not designed
for that and it wouldn't be very good
for that they turned it into that a lot
from the very complicated problems yes
added for many many years it's made hot
i also found yourself sending photos on
the cell phone concept quite powerful
man winch woodman send sending photos oh
yes taken out the door myself I'm very
powerful I use a little bit the sense
cam yes hmm know that we have man and
that's also the main idea that you're
taking photos grand interesting times
and we mean the data
I think the the reason this was actually
acceptable to the people we showed it to
was that it was such a targeted location
that they felt it was ok they really did
not want pictures and video in the rest
of the house because they didn't want to
feel like they had to do their hair
every time they walked through the
living room that kind of thing but at
the door they could see why it would be
useful and they didn't go to the door
unless they were going to see someone
else anyway and so that was okay and so
the sense cam I think I mean it's a
fascinating project but I don't know how
comfortable ders would be with that just
because they they want to know and they
want it have it targeted at a location
where they don't feel like they're there
they're having their picture taken when
they're not expecting it oh yeah I can
understand that yeah one last
observation given your experiment with
hours on the door I'm sure you are aware
the security company like Ed tease very
Christian expanding into the space great
one white health care monitoring in
solana cake services and I think that's
going to be really popular in the future
even though a person might not want
their daughter seeing something almost
universally they had no problem with an
ADT having that information or an ADT if
there was video monitoring and it was an
ATT person who was watching it to see if
they had fallen that was ok compared to
maybe the video showing up on their
daughters you know desktop in a little
frame or something they didn't like that
or their friends seeing it but an ATT
that's a service you're paying for and
they saw the value of that and and they
like that but but again I have to say in
general people could see someone else
using it they have a very hard time
thinking that they're going to need that
and by it you know you have those
buttons where you feel if you fall you
press it in it and it sends an alert
even people who had fallen and our focus
groups didn't think that they needed it
yet and it was always someone else and
so you have that barrier that people
don't see themselves as aging so
actually getting them to use the
technology or purchase the technology
might be difficult yeah enjoy
so talking about the do you think that
the children who are receiving the
picture is leaving the sort of
scaffolding fire and either interpreting
or sifting through all these pictures
because is it like all day there
everything should be getting well so
it's every time either someone rings the
doorbell if it's that version or if
someone opens the door and so it in some
ways if you have someone who is very
active and always going in and out that
that door opening one isn't going to be
appropriate for them all right because
you're going to have so many pictures
that they're not going to know what to
do but the doorbell one most people
don't have a lot of people ringing their
doorbell so so that would make more
sense and it tends to be I think the
people who would use the technology more
are people who are becoming less capable
of going out a lot more you know they
might be starting to early-stage
Alzheimer's or something like that and
and so it really becomes I mean it's the
same thing as any kind of intrusion
detection system right the false
positives can make it so it's not very
useful and you have to you have to gauge
that and I think it's going to be on an
individual situation I don't know what
kind of scaffolding we can do this is
actually a gene camps project more than
mine but that's an interesting question
it is there a way to support it beyond
just showing them pictures can we do any
kind of processing to help them gauge
what's actually going on would be
interesting thanks
any questions yes so you ever think
about how
the elders for example not really grown
up with the technology drive a lot of
conclusions there especially about all
right we've got people now the kids that
are born texting how they will Olivia
mediums likely change absolutely it's
something that we struggle with a lot
because the current cohort of elders
you're right they're not as technology
savvy as the ones who are about to
retire so something that we've done is
we're actually working with a retirement
community that are early adopters
essentially they are technology savvy
and they're more reflective of the
majority of elders that are coming up
but that doesn't necessarily reflect the
entire population and we recognize that
is kind of the low-hanging through the
easy population to target right now so
the next iteration of what we're looking
at looking for funding for right now is
to start looking at the other side of
the digital divide and we're actually
going to start looking at urban centers
and people who have different community
settings even you know maybe their kids
don't move away and so they're not as as
far away from the children as the ones
we're looking at now and they have
different technology experiences as well
they you're absolutely right different
cohorts they're going to have different
experience life experiences and that is
going to impact how they think about the
technology and how they use the
technology and it's something we just
have to try to account for but and tell
you until tell you get old enough to use
it we're not going to know you know
other questions all right thank you